one question
if we win just how much do we get one
very special detail on set could have
helped the squid game players survive
from giant dolls to mind-bending stairs
inspired by a piece of art the team
behind squid game went all out with
their sets
while cgi is used to create or complete
certain images many of the sets and
backdrops seen in squid game were
fabricated just for the show this is
extra impressive because some of the
real sets look like they could be
created by computers with just how
mesmerizing and exciting they look
especially when the backdrops appear to
be outdoor locations tug of war might
seem like a simple enough game to film
but the team behind the netflix hit
opted to build a large space and the
raised platforms used in the game from
scratch the space created managed to be
the perfect base for the actors to
perform on and to add cgi effects
afterwards to make the space seem as
daunting as it feels for the actors
every inch had to be precisely built to
ensure the safety of the performers
while doing such physical work
the dorms the players stay in during
squid game may be the dullest colored
set but it's certainly not the least
impressive the grey walls and metal bunk
beds aren't so inviting or comforting
but they definitely set the scene and
make an impact the size of the space was
so vast that for the performers it could
feel like they were in a coliseum the
dorm space is where so much happens a
major fight learning the truth of the
game watching the money add up and the
prison-like aesthetic provided the ideal
backdrop for these pivotal moments
if you do not wish to participate
then please let us know at this time not
a single detail was overlooked when the
art department and creative team worked
to bring all the spaces we see in squid
game to the screen
one very small but meaningful detail one
that even could have helped the players
out a bit was hiding in plain sight on
the walls
tajikido
we don't see them in the first part of
the series but as players lose and there
isn't a need for so many beds we slowly
see the images revealed all the
illustrations on the walls depict each
of the games played throughout the
series the fact that the bunk beds were
in tall stacks was no coincidence either
the art director thought them up to
convey themes of abandonment and
carrying emotional baggage
they were actually made out of the same
material as tunnels
the colorful and unsettling sets of
staircases we see in squid game were
actually inspired by a famous piece of
art called relativity the original image
came from the mind of a dutch artist
named mcesher
the squid game creative team felt the
mind-bending picture would be the
perfect addition to the series and they
weren't wrong
the original photo includes seven
stairways arranged in a world where
gravity is different and considering
squid game really turns every player's
life upside down whether they want it to
or not the homage paid to this classic
piece of art makes a lot of sense and
just adds to the genius of the show
whoa this place is gigantic
a part of what makes these sets so
incredible is the sheer scale of them
the space of the children's playground
for the honeycomb game featured real
enormous versions of playground
equipment with a fake drawn sky
background making the whole scene look
like an image we'd see in a children's
book it did an incredible job at
bringing us a freaky playground vibe the
large-scale equipment also helped with
making the players feel like children
replicating what the environment would
have looked like to them when they were
young the team definitely accomplished
the formidable but also familiar and
reminiscent of childhood look that
director huang was hoping to achieve
so our options are circle triangle
star umbrella
we can't discuss the incredible sets
without mentioning one very impactful
prop
if that's what we call a creepy giant
doll that had the power to take any
player out that it saw moving the red
light green light doll is a major part
of the scene for the initial game and
shockingly wasn't created just for the
show yes this terrifying giant mugunkwat
doll actually existed before and was
displayed for the public to see at a
museum adventure village in south korea
the doll is back in its original home
since the production wrap so people can
see this amazing piece of the squid game
story in person
it seems like the games were tough for
the doll as well since it now is
inexplicably missing one of its hands
some cast members were actually
speechless when they were on set for the
first time thrilled by the fact that
they'd get to interact and perform in
these incredible spaces the actor who
plays number one had a really intense
nostalgic reaction when he was on set
where the marbles game takes place
all the houses and streets we see were
built from the ground up no small feat
but so worth the final incredible
product the set had the power to
transport the cast members themselves to
other places so it's no surprise they've
completely captured us
for director of the series huang it was
important to build an authentic world so
the team could more easily tell the
story truthfully meaning not a lot of
cgi ended up being used
not a corner was cut and the squid game
team decided to really build everything
we see oftentimes extremely large
versions which only added to the
impressive production one of the coolest
examples of a non-cgi shot is the very
first game red light green light where
there were actually over 400 performers
on the set playing the game oftentimes
in scenes like these loads of people end
up being added in with cgi but since the
set itself was so enormous they were
able to accommodate a massive cast and
crew
over there looks really freaky for the
performers seeing the sets for the first
time blew them away and they needed to
capture the magic
the cast had of course had time with the
script for a while before they arrived
to film and when reading naturally
thought up of what the sets were going
to look like for the most part it was
not at all what they'd expected and some
actors were even caught off guard
shocked that these incredible spaces
existed and that they were the lucky
actors who got to perform on them for
other actors the set felt a bit like a
fantasy or dream world
the colors in childlike structures are
surprising and catch audiences off guard
in a fantastic way as well the sheer
scale of it all was overwhelming but the
performers managed to fill the space
right up with their incredible acting
with so many interesting locations it's
a bit surprising that the whole
production is filmed in just one city
about an hour outside of seoul south
korea is daejeon this city has been the
home base for many south korean
productions and is now home to squid
game where so much magic was created
since there wasn't any big traveling
being done the budget for the set could
be a bit higher and the team took
advantage of it
these creations were far from cheap i
think that's what you said the sets of
squid game are a major contributor to
why the show has become such a hit they
really play characters of their own and
add massive amounts of info and energy
to the story they somehow managed to
make childlike images terrifying and
present unsettling scenes we couldn't
even have thought up in our worst
nightmares which set were you most
excited by